[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by lamorne morris
and blake anderson who star in woke
season two which is out friday on hulu
how are you guys doing today doing great
fantastic
awesome so lamorn with the character of
keith you know having your scene partner
sometimes being an inanimate object what
is exactly going on set there what are
you actually like talking to that's not
a nice thing to say about me man
honestly it's like talking to a wall
like anderson um
no
it's what's really happening is i'm
talking to marshall todd marshall todd
is our uh one of our creators and
writers uh and uh and producers of the
show and uh he has a very powerful and
hilarious voice and a funny way of
delivering
and
so most of the time if i'm talking to a
marker
you know there's a you know a cable i
don't wanna you know go into the sausage
so much but
there's something's happening there but
there's a voice on this side talking to
me and it's usually marshall todd who
sounds like if samuel jackson uh did
steroids
like uh
like
he is a giant dude
and he says mf a lot you know so uh so
that's uh
that's what it's like uh talking to a
marker
no i love that answer and it's cool then
seeing it come and post with all these
big actors and actors doing the voices
and it comes out great uh
blake you know we see now we're gonna
see in season two that gunther is taking
care of plants and now i'm seeing your
background you have plants behind you
nature are you into this at all in real
life with plants is that something you
have any interest in
uh well you know everybody dealt with uh
quarantine in different ways uh you know
some of us found our best friends to be
succulents and uh
so yeah
even though you know it's a harsh
reality most plants i
own i end up killing so it's just like
okay it's a life lesson all around we
can all learn something from the plant
world
yeah hell yeah don't don't don't take up
occupancy in your home yeah
avoid me if you're a plant you're better
off on the side of the road
i love that now lamorin keith being
based off of keith knight
how much freedom do you have in season
two like with someone you're portraying
is there like more freedom as the show
goes on to like kind of expand how
you're betraying him or do you have to
kind of stay in a certain area with that
yeah i mean you get some freedom i think
season one there was more pressure to
kind of uh be
uh more keith like you know as an actor
you just you find yourself in you know
embodying the character a lot more and
you're with him every day he's always on
set um he's one of the writers as well
so he's always you know dropping little
nuggets in your ear and and you know
you know this is how i would say it
things like that but
you know we didn't want this to be an
impression of him we didn't want this we
wanted it just to be about him and i
happened to be the person playing him
but i did want to have very similar
cadences in the way that i speak in the
you know certain you know think clothes
that i wear and things like that we
definitely want this to be about
him
but not um
not a direct uh parody if you will of
him yeah you're not like imitating
that's that's a great answer and yeah
you you just do it awesome and
you know
no problem blake though with the show
like this you know comes internet trolls
right like that say stuff like go oh go
broke like how do you do these people
get under your skin at all or have you
learned to just kind of tune that out
i mean i think in all aspects of life we
have to
learn the tools required to navigate
social media you know we are kind of the
guinea pigs of this generation of
figuring it out and it
doesn't really look like it's going
anywhere anytime soon but
yeah it's all about navigating that
stuff you know all these people they're
just hiding behind keyboards and all
that stuff but i i don't let it deter me
in the work that i do i believe in the
show i believe in the product i believe
in the message so if i'm cool with it
then you know trolls will be trolls
hell yeah i preach uh
lamorin i am very excited about this new
girl recap podcast you're doing welcome
to our show and you're getting an
awesome guest which is cool too was this
something you always wanted to do like
does it bring you joy doing that uh it
does it does and you know it wasn't
something i always knew was possible i
just know that whenever i was doing
interviews or you know talking to fans i
would constantly be reliving those
moments constantly telling stories you
know fans ask me questions all the time
and i would always engage and talk about
it and we would do panels and
you know and then in this world of you
know re-watch podcasts we we we thought
hey let's talk about it we did that show
like we we did that show let's you know
when fans have a lot of questions and
you do want to relive some of those
moments i mean blake knows what i'm
talking about you know we we you you're
you're catching up with old friends and
you're just like on our podcast we do
read what we do recap the episodes but
we're also just catching up with each
other talking about our own personal
stories um now that we're much older
when you know then we you know when we
started when we started the show and our
perspectives looking back on things that
happened 10 years ago you know
yeah and that's what i love about both
you guys that you're both on these huge
shows that still are in people's minds
and watching that you guys acknowledge
that and you're not acting too cool for
it which i love oh yeah you can't be too
you know school man camping can't be now
i'm not really cool i don't have to
worry about it that's true yes okay well
i see it your way now yeah
blake i need you to answer the question
on everyone's mind here that are
watching this is how can the oakland a's
get back to their glory days like the
moneyball days what do they got to do
dude i mean if you know oakland a's
baseball it's a lot of like build just
to destroy you've got a small window
you roll the dice you play the lotto and
it looks like uh the time was up for
this team and let's start again fresh
face hopefully my only concern at this
point as a fan is that they keep the a's
in oakland because you know oakland is
such an amazing city with amazing
history and i have so many good memories
of the oakland athletics growing up i
just hope they can keep them in the bay
yeah you don't want them leaving like
the raiders did that's
vegas is on the horizon even though
that'd be kind of cool to go watch
baseball in las vegas true true
it's a good like four hour break from
drinking well actually you're going to
be drinking at the game a good four hour
break from dan
[Laughter]
love that now lamorin you post on
instagram in january a picture of you as
spider-man you know that will get people
going crazy
is that your favorite superhero and
would you ever want to play one
i
i am playing spider-man i am the next
spider-man i oh yeah
i didn't want to i didn't you know i
didn't know how to break it to the folks
out there but i am
i killed tom holland
in real life uh
this is my plan no
um uh
uh spider-man is definitely one of my
favorite superheroes um i would say
silver surfer and gambit are my my
favorite too i've always wanted to play
gambit it was
like you know
channing tatum was going to play gambit
or something you know but i'm putting
this out there in the universe that i
should play gambit and yeah
that's that's my dream you definitely
have
you definitely have that creole vibe
that kind of like
suave frenchman
i could do it i could do it i could do i
could
because he's from new orleans you don't
talk about bro so yeah i play gambit
like that right though you know what i'm
saying hey you got the part baby
i'm gonna call you like two players
[Laughter]
you wanna see me okay is this your card
bam right
[Laughter]
um blake is comedy always where you kind
of have your eye at to want to do each
next gig or is it like you ever consider
seeing yourself doing more dramatic
roles
uh
i mean i i'm always open to it but
comedy is has always been what i've been
drawn to ever since i was in you know
elementary school or middle school when
i first like discovered like improv it
was just like this is where i feel most
free and you know i i really
you know maybe it's deep down
psychologically just like to make people
laugh and feel good and you know it's
just
it's the best medicine it continues to
be so
i'm just uh
yeah i'm always looking for community
doctor are you saying you're a doctor i
i am at this point i am i'm a doctor of
the funnies i respect that i respect you
got it
well thank you guys for being funny here
today making my day everyone make sure
to watch lamorin and blake
crush it in woke season two it's on hulu
on friday thank you guys for joining me
today we'll talk to you in the future
one day yes thank you steve